Oh
Oh
you
midway through part 4 of the discourse
on method the card is going to start
talking about God and you might wonder
why is he bringing up God at this point
well the reason that he's doing so as
we'll see as we get towards the end of
this is that he needs God there as a
kind of principle to provide him with
some certainty about two things one is
that anything that we perceive clearly
and distinctly will actually be true and
then about the external world because if
we apply this methodological doubt and
we sweep everything away even if we have
the coach ito the I think therefore I am
and we have the fact that we're thinking
substance were distinct from our body so
long as we think we exist and we even
have this criteria that we think is
going to work a clear and distinct ideas
that doesn't actually yield us any
knowledge about the external world yet
or about anything beyond just our minds
so we're stuck you might say within the
orbit of what it is that that we think
we want to get out of that to other
things now in de cartes view unless we
can actually be certain that not only
that God exists but that God is a
certain kind of being we're not going to
have certainty about all these other
things and it's important to pause for a
moment to think about what occurred
actually means my god does he mean the
god of the scriptures you know the Old
Testament the New Testament no because
all of us been thrown away through
methodological doubt there's no church
teachings there's no you know scriptures
or anything like that that is giving us
an understanding of God he's saying that
we can come up with a conception of God
is perfect being this is what we would
call the god of the Philosopher's is not
the god of the theologians as a matter
of fact blade as poss phallus is going
to criticize Descartes one of the carts
contemporaries it's going to criticize
Descartes very us
strongly on this point he's saying that
he uses God to get everything moving and
then doesn't bother with him again after
that and there's there's a certain truth
to that in fact and as we'll see now the
way that this works in his mind
Descartes says I know that I'm a being
who doubts and I also know that doubting
can be compared against knowing as
imperfection to a state that's more
perfect now what does he mean my
perfection here that's something that if
you want to understand this text it's
really important to get a grasp on when
we think about perfection as a term
today we think of it in a very narrow
conception that's not quite the same
sense that Descartes is using it in we
tend to think of perfection as being
absolute perfection something that is
perfect is totally without flaws so we
don't tend to think of perfect as a
thing that could be more or less but for
decart something can be more perfect or
less perfect there's a comparative
aspect to it being perfect means to be
as much as it could be and some things
can be compared against each other so we
can speak of beings as being more
perfect or having more perfections
having more capacities to do what it is
that they do so we are more perfect so
to speak then say animals or pieces of
chalk we possess more perfections one of
those perfections would be having a will
or having the capacity to reason now
notice that we don't necessarily reason
perfectly in every case but having the
capacity to reason is itself a
perfection so here we've realized that
doubting knowing imperfection more
perfection we have a conception of
something being more perfect how do we
have that conception how did that get
into our heads well we're actually
presuming an idea of some more perfect
being
in doing so now notice that the cart
does not just say that we have an idea
of the more perfect or of perfection he
talks about a being or a substance or a
thing that's more perfect strictly
speaking perfection isn't something that
can kind of hang out there in a void
even as an idea is a quality or a
predicate of something now you notice
that i have this more here de cartas
beginning with the conception of a more
perfect being ultimately we're going to
want to get to the notion of perfect
being as such and that is the idea of
God how can we go from more to to
entirely perfect well you know the curt
doesn't spell this out but you can think
this out on your own by a process sort
of along these lines if you can think of
a more perfect being can you think of a
being that's even more perfect than that
just add another perfection or take away
some imperfection and eventually you're
going to reach some limit point where
you've got something that is totally
perfect and that's an idea in your mind
at this point now here's where it gets
really interesting Descartes says let's
think about our ideas I've got ideas of
all sorts of things like the sky the
earth light heat thousand dollars where
did these ideas come from why I don't
know yet but you know they don't there's
no real mystery about where they came
from maybe they came from me maybe I
made them up and I told myself some sort
of story and there isn't really a sky
and earth and all that that sort of
physical phenomenon but you know those
could be ideas that I manufactured in my
own mind could be something that came to
me from something else doesn't require
any sort of perfection in order to
produce those ideas what about this idea
though the idea of perfect being could
they have come from say nothing maybe
just sort of popped into my head well
that doesn't work because what comes
from nothing nothing and this isn't
nothing this is really a something isn't
it this is a big something this is a
bigger something then you know a lot of
other things so the idea of a perfect
being is a different kind of idea they
had other ideas according to Descartes
it contains something more in it it
can't be coming from nothing it has to
have some sort of source could it have
come to me from the outside world you
know people somebody whispered in my ear
perfect being perfect being well no
because we don't have an outside world
yet at this point do we we have been
talking as if we had pushed everything
away in methodological down so I can't
rely on any sort of hearsay from
somebody else as being the source of
this where else could it have come from
well um maybe yeah yeah perfect being
came from myself maybe it came from my
own mind maybe I created it but this
raises some big problems because it
doesn't really answer the question to
say well where did I get this idea that
I'm not sure you know the source of well
i got it for myself but the question is
where did I actually get this idea it
doesn't do any good to say I got the
idea that I found mysteriously in my
mind because my mind manufactured it
because I'm the question is still well
how did they get there in your mind we
can kick it upstairs a couple times but
you're still not answering the question
and why can't this idea come from me he
says it's no less unacceptable that
something more perfect should be a
consequence I'll been dependent on
something less perfect than that
something should come from nothing
I could not derive this idea from myself
why because I don't have perfection so
where then did I get this idea from
we've eliminated all the other
possibilities so the one possibility
that's left is something that is outside
of myself independent of me that this
idea is in some way a reflection or
image or sign or whatever you want to
call it off he says I concluded the idea
had been put in me by a nature which was
truly more perfect than I was even one
which contained in itself all the
perfections about which I could have
some idea that is to say to explain
myself in a single phrase a nature which
was God so God is not only a more
perfect being God is a being which
contains all the possible perfections
that i can think of all possible
perfections that I can possibly conceive
of this is supposed to be an argument
for the existence of God not just as an
idea in our head but is something extra
mental something that is that we can
think of but which exists outside of
ourselves and the idea that we have in
our head reflects the reality of
something greater than that idea greater
than us so this is kind of a tricky
proof here people are not entirely sure
sometimes how to classify this in the
arguments for God's existence so he says
what else can we say about God so this I
added the fact that since I know about
some perfections I don't have I was not
the only being that existed but it must
of necessity be the case that there was
some other more perfect being on whom I
depended in
whom I acquired all that I here why
because if I exist if I had been alone
an independent of everything else so
that I derived for myself all perfection
I would have been able to have for
myself for the same reasons all the
additional perfections that I knew I
lacked and thus be myself infinite
eternal immutable all-knowing
all-powerful and finally have all the
perfections which I could observe as
being present in God so what he's saying
is I don't know how many things there
are in the universe but there have to be
at least two it can't just be me and my
mind and my thinking there has to be
something else and that's something else
can't be something less than me or equal
to me it's got to be something greater
than me upon which I depend something
else that possesses all possible
perfections that is God so he goes on
and he says I want to understand the
nature of God I've talked about the
existence of God now we need to know
about what God is actually like so he
says all they have to do is think about
all the things which I found some idea
within me and then consider whether that
thing was a perfection or not if it is a
perfection in me then it's going to be
over here in God as well if it's not a
perfection me like for example doubting
then it's not going to be in God and
this raises a really interesting
question doesn't it seems as if God is
then lacking something that Descartes or
any other human being would have and a
current uses a couple other examples
that are too feeling regret feeling
sadness doubting are those really things
that God lacks or are those in effect
something lacking with it
you notice I've taken away there's not
nothing here but really doubting in some
respect comes from our participation in
nothingness we are as Descartes says
caught between God perfect being and
nothingness our being is not full being
let an interesting thing to think about
so our imperfections are actually lakhs
of something rather than presences of
something and they're not going to be in
the perfect being that possesses all
perfections and possesses no
imperfections there's another thing as
well he says I had several I had ideas
about sensible and corporeal things that
means things that we can see with our
senses and things that are bottling he
thought about these things and he
realizes that all corporeal all bodily
all extended things as he says in
indicate dependency and dependency as a
defect they can change they can break
down they can be divided into parts so
that means that God is not going to be
bodily God is going to be incorporeal
God is more like a mind than God is like
a by as a matter of fact God is you
might say a third kind of substance
besides my body there's also God but
this is a lot more like mine than it is
like body so he says God's perfection
could not consist of being composed of
two nature's like ours mind and body and
thus he was thus he was not but if there
were some bodies in the world they're
being had to depend on God's power in
such a way as they could not subsist a
single moment without so if there is an
external world of bodies
which would include my own that depends
upon God's creative power and God
sustaining that and being so there is an
external world for me to know in a
certain respect I got to go through God
to get to it that sounds a little funny
doesn't so he goes out a little bit
further he says that that's fine but I
want to know other truths so I proposed
to myself the subject matter of
geometric that means geometry or
something that I can reason out with my
own capacities in my mind now geometry
pertains to the external world of bodies
but in a way it's abstracting from it
and the way that geometry works is as we
seen by proofs long lines of
argumentation so he said can I can i buy
these proofs can I accept these now why
is this an issue remember one of the
things that was swept away in
methodological doubt was the ability to
trust our own reasonings unless we see
clearly and distinctly that the ideas
must be true that they follow so he has
an example here about triangles if we
have a triangle and the thing about the
nature of the triangle right here is a
triangle right here not the best
triangle but we know one thing about
triangles the angles all have to add up
to 180 degrees at least afford Euclidean
geometry you're doing non-euclidean
geometry okay you take heart didn't know
about non-euclidean geometry so he says
this is a property of a triangle so if
you actually do a triangle it's got to
add up to 180 degrees there's there's no
way about that that doesn't mean you
necessarily have to have triangle but if
you do have a triangle then it follows
right so we're like saying if somebody
is a thief they must have stolen
something because they can't be a thief
without having stolen something maybe
nobody ever steals anything there are no
thieves but if somebody were to steal
something then that person would be a
thief wait if somebody is a thief then
they must have stolen something right
the card is actually going to apply this
to God because one of the perfections we
can talk about is in fact existence and
here he's going to give us a different
argument for the existence of God this
one by the way corresponds to the
argument in one of his other books the
meditations in meditation five the
argument that we developed so far
corresponds to the argument in
meditation three he's got this argument
from existence where he says if we think
about the nature of triangle and then we
think about the nature of God existence
is a perfection God is a perfect being
so if there is even the conception of a
perfect being that must include
existence within it so God cannot not
exist God must exist he says the idea of
God it includes the idea of existence
put in other ways he says it's just as
certain that gob this perfect being is
or exists as any geometric proof can can
be and he says why do people have
problems with this why do people didn't
think God doesn't exist well because
they're not accustomed to thinking about
these things just on the basis of
thought alone but they're always using
their imagination they're imagining that
God is something like bodies the same
logic doesn't apply to physical
corporeal bodies as does to God or the
human mind so if we don't use our
intellect but rely on our imagination
we're not going to understand this so he
goes on me says something else here and
here we have to erase alone here we're
going to get to something that people
sometimes have trouble with in the carts
line of argument
and it's called the Cartesian circle
here's how we get to it so we know that
God exists and we've just talked about
the argument for that now God exists
that means that a being of you know
perfect being exists that's really the
same thing and what is one of the
perfections or rather let's think about
something that's an imperfection could
God be a deceiver could God be lying to
us could God be sending us for example
images of things that aren't really true
that aren't really a veridical that
don't add up to the way that reality is
that wouldn't make sense because
goodness is a perfection whereas being a
Seaver is sign of lack of perfection why
do people try to trick other people
sometimes it's because they want to
steal something from them they want to
get something from them they want to
have power over them any time that
somebody does that that's a sign that
they're screwed up in some way they lack
a certain perfection God wouldn't do
that sort of thing because God doesn't
have any of those sort of motives not
because God simply is good and doesn't
have a little notice but because those
motives wouldn't go along with being a
perfect being they would be an
imperfection they would be a lack of
being they would be in effect the sort
of bleeding into to God of nothingness
and that doesn't make sense according to
Descartes so since God is not a deceiver
we can be confident about what comes
from God and what does come from God
well our nature as beings that think one
of the things that is actually going to
come from God is this notion that clear
and distinct ideas are true so what this
means is if we stick to the realm of
clear and distinct ideas we're not going
to go wrong why not because God Himself
the perfect being has set things up in
such a way so as if we stick with these
we will reach the truth so long as we
don't allow say our imaginations or our
commitments based on our are willing or
our action to outstrip our intellect
what it is that we actually know our
capacity to reason we will be able to
stay within the realm of the truth that
means that if we're going to study
bodies we want to approach them not just
by looking at them because you know
census can be deceptive but by thinking
about them in terms of their properties
we want to do science this is what gives
Descartes the capacity to say science
can reach the answers not only about the
mind not only about God but about the
physical universe about our bodies about
animals about technology about the
entire cosmos now there's a problem here
because how do we know that God exists
this is at the end of the chain right
clear and distinct ideas are true but
when we were making the argument that
God exists weren't we also relying upon
clear and distinct ideas to make that
argument how do we know that when we did
that reasoning earlier about perfect
beings and where they could come from
and ideas and all that how do we know
that we weren't screwing up just like
somebody who makes a mistake and
rithmetic or makes a mistake in logic
with a long chain of argumentation this
is what we call this this whole thing
the Cartesian circle and one of the
criticisms that's made of dickering on
this account is that he's really engaged
in a circular process of reasoning now
the curt is smart enough to know that
this does look circular the current
weight of responding to this is to say
no it appears to be circular but you
know what what's going on is God does in
fact exist and that's what gives us the
clear and distinct idea is that we would
need in order to be able to see that God
exists but it's not like I'm making God
it's not like I'm manufacturing him with
my ideas my ideas are corresponding to
something that's actually there and that
thing that's actually there is giving me
the capacity to rely on these clear and
distinct ideas whether or not you accept
the Cartesian circle you now see where
he's going with this line of argument
what's he going to draw as a conclusion
he says now after the knowledge of God
in the soul in this way has made a
certain of this rule that I can trust
clear and distinct perceptions it's easy
to see that the dreams we imagine well
sleep shouldn't make us doubt the truth
of the thoughts we have while awake for
if it happened even while we were
sleeping we had some really distinct
idea for example a geometers annu proof
in his sleep or her sleep the fact that
they're asleep doesn't prevent it from
being true and as for error it doesn't
matter that the most common dreams we
have do can give us occasion a challenge
the truth of such ideas because these
ideas can
also mislead us when we're not asleep so
he says weather or awake or asleep we
should never allow ourselves to be
persuaded except by the evidence of our
reason our reason not our imagination or
our senses and it gives the example of
the Sun when we look at the Sun the Sun
looks like a little dot and so we might
imagine that the Sun is two inches wide
or something like that and that's what
our senses are giving us even our
imagination might give it to us that way
our reason is what tells us that it's
something like if I remember right 93
million miles away from us and many
times larger than the earth that is our
reason that does that when we see an
animal for example we have sense
perception of that we imagine things but
if we were to truly understanding animal
we would think about in terms of the
mechanism of its body that's corporeal
parts and how they all fit together so
what we've got here now is having begun
from a principle of methodological doubt
that swept away seemingly everything we
now have a universe that we can
understand but only through the
capacities of reason and science and we
have ourselves that we can understand
through reflection upon ourselves and we
have got can we really understand God
according to Descartes not so much and
he doesn't talk about God very much from
this point on but you see the role that
the argument about God's existence and
about God's nature plays in his
philosophy